come talk to me over here okay
right here nobody talks to be right here
listen to me it's what okay okay I got
you I'll talk to you they can't go far
though Antonio listen okay
let's say back up let him get his suit
so yeah probably you want to talk to me
right here you want to talk to me over
here
okay well talk to me what's going on I
can't really hear you though
you want to crack it a little bit
you wanna go the window
hey Antonio you're not in trouble okay
okay well
okay
God damn
it
he just
I'll I'll talk to you
crack ass so I can hear you you know
what I mean
foreign
they're over there it's only me I'm
right here you're not you're not in
trouble man you you know you you
remember me right
yeah you remember me right I wrote yes
yes
okay I wrote the I wrote the report for
you remember that right
the whole time I was cool with you right
okay so let's just talk let's let's
go okay
you wanna talk to me on the phone
I'm on my phone
on the phone
okay
do you have us do you have a screen on
the front door
I mean just so I can talk to it so I can
hear you just
you wanna go front door
yeah yeah
we're gonna transition our front door
it's only me
I can't hear you
you too brother you want you want to
just crack it a little it's just it's
only me I mean
right
so let's do this can we at least give
her back her ID and stuff real quick can
we do that
oh you don't have it there's nothing in
there
so there's no purse or nothing in it
nothing up okay
foreign
I know I know well that's why when I saw
the call I actually they didn't call me
because they don't
well that's what I'm saying I I remember
I saw the call and I was like hey maybe
he'll talk to me
because we had a good interaction you
know what I mean
well listen no matter
right so no matter what happens you're
gonna just deal with me that's it it's
very easy you know we're not here to
fight with you we don't want you know
what's that
it's all it's always it's always been
like that it's always been like that
with me and you I took that
okay okay
so so let me ask you this are you
willing to talk to me besides this
foreign
no no I understand I know you're not
doing it to me I just can't hear you
so let me do this let me see if because
she talked about ID in a purse let me
see
yeah yeah let me just see what else
she's talking about and I'll I'll ask
you if it's in there is that cool
I I believe you I believe you
right no no I understand let me just see
what she says can you just give me one
second all right don't go just hang out
okay so
um yeah I've got time to get the food
yeah so
the ultimate goal is what uh pausing
video to speaking officers
and Tony talk to me dude
okay so so let me tell you
we're running out of options for her to
get her stuff I don't know where her
stuff is she says it's in there I don't
know
but let me just tell you this I don't
want this to happen Okay so I'm talking
to you
talk to your man-to-man okay man to man
oh no I will but look just hear me out
first listen listen to me between me and
you
if you don't let her in to get her
things I'm telling you because it's out
of my hands but I'm just warning you
because I'm telling you man to man okay
if you don't let her in
I'm telling you
if she wanted to have that dude do the
lock thing
she can
but listen
if she does that she's technically still
a resident here until the eviction
process is because there's still seven
days left on the eviction
but but listen to me and listen you're
not in trouble you're not gonna I know I
know but I want you to hear from me
you're not in trouble you're not gonna
get her you're not gonna get arrested
okay
so listen
so listen me and you me and you will
hang out
speaker speak louder
copy that I'm I'm telling them right now
no I believe you but listen yeah
you can't no no
and Antonio I know I know listen
listen I know that it's not me it's not
me yeah I'm not doing
no no I understand and this is and this
is and this is why I'm here this is I
can't talk to you like this man and
listen this is this is why I'm here
because
they're they're giving me
five minutes they're giving me five
minutes
no no
you're not you're still not no no you're
still not in trouble you can still talk
to me me and you
listen since since this residence I know
it's under a corporation I understand
that I get it I'm not I'm not disputing
that
even if it is she still has lived here
this is just for my I know this is my
understanding I don't know I've only
I've only got here five minutes ago I'm
just telling you since she has lived
here if she wanted to break a window you
want she brother she can I'm just
telling you and there's no repercussions
I know I know what you're not you're I
know you're not happy with that I'm just
telling you huh
I know what you're saying but I'm not
here to dispute either way
oh I know I know you're not I know
you're not I know you're not
oh the solution is just to let her get
her stuff and that's it
oh and I would I would be with you I'll
walk I'll hang out with you while she
gets it I'll I'll go with her
no no listen you want me to go with her
I can go with her
she'll leave she will
trust me so if you want I will walk with
her so she don't take nothing and then
we'll get it and she'll leave and that's
it
yeah let's do that
hey hey
yeah we can do it yep
make me make me look good make me look
good that's it but I'll go with her so
she don't
but let me go her though yep yep you
want me to get her okay
hey um what's your name
she's walking up yeah yeah I'll walk in
with her and you take this
yeah
okay yeah
she's walking in
what is this
from where I mean I make it some of that
later no no wait listen you and me are
good no I don't care about the weed I
don't care about that myself huh you
know what I mean when she comes here I'm
gonna go with her but listen
okay
exactly yes
yes
I'm gonna walk with her when she I'm
gonna leave with her you know what I
mean
right here yep
[Music]
no no
Antonio
listen it's for me it's for me because
I'm walking in the house by myself it's
for me
foreign
no no no don't do anything just just
hang out
it's only going to be it's only gonna be
me going in
it's only me going in exactly it's only
me and her going in
right here
listen to me she's gonna leave I got it
trust me I got it
let's get our stuff and that's it no no
he's gotta be he's got to be close he's
got he has to be he has to be clear he's
not going to come in he's gonna be just
right up in here come in your house it's
only me Antonio just so we could be done
with this man
he's super paranoid man like super
I mean
he's just afraid she's not gonna leave I
mean that's the only thing Mr Brown
listen she's gonna leave I'm Gonna Stand
by the door I will not come in your
house only me okay only only me that's
it
she will leave she'll get her stuff and
leave and we're going to leave
okay I'm just gonna stand on the
sidewalk for his protection that's it
okay listen have I lied to you did I not
give did I not give you your food in
good faith
I can't hear you
so let me see hold on hold on Pete
foreign
that's a good faith effort
in the open door I'm gonna walk away
we don't want you know we don't want to
fight with you you know that
happened he's gonna start drilling he's
going to come look he's going to come to
the door it's going to be it's going to
be a confrontation and it's going to be
hopefully we got to do something about
it
you know um I and it's a little steel
porch you saw that it's not like a whole
bunch of people is that what we gotta do
is that what we got this one he wants to
drill okay
so safety-wise
right well yeah I mean for our advantage
we can see him before he's gonna see us
take it Through the Windows if it's dark
out here
Sophie if you want I mean I'll go first
or whatever and I'll see I'll be like
hey man I'll try to talk to him first
and I'll just I'll go Hands-On she has
to invite us in that's it
she says yes okay based on the
supervisors
but I'm just saying as far as
if you can win you know what I mean like
you and I were just going and going you
know what I mean
um and then if you have to go maybe less
things I mean go do that
um
zero that's what I'm saying while the
thing is failing and what's gonna happen
if he says hey they're trying to break
in my house or something you know what I
mean I don't know that's what I'm gonna
try to say but that's
right
that may that may anger him a little bit
you know what I mean like him seeing you
and stuff like that probably not a good
idea